in Japan an Innovative approach to
watermelon cultivation has given rise to
a unique and fascinating phenomenon
square watermelons
unlike their traditional round
counterparts these watermelons are grown
inside square boxes resulting in their
distinctive shape
Japan known for its limited space sought
a solution to efficiently utilize
available storage areas
by growing watermelons in boxes farmers
can stack them neatly optimizing storage
capacity and transportation efficiency
the process involves placing young
watermelon fruits inside transparent
containers allowing them to grow and
assume the shape of the box
this meticulous cultivation technique
requires constant monitoring and precise
adjustments to ensure the desired
outcome
while the square watermelons do not
differ in taste or nutritional value
from their rounded Brethren they have
become a symbol of Ingenuity and
resourcefulness in Japanese agriculture